i
[Música]
ah
la administración de job aiden apoya
relajar las protecciones de patentes de
las vacunas contra el coi 19 con el fin
de acabar con la pandemia a nivel global
a algo que le permitirá a los países con
menos recursos y más afectados por el
cob y 19 como india entre otros que
puedan producir así sus propias vacunas
genéricas sin tener que esperar meses o
incluso años por las dosis sin embargo
las empresas farmacéuticas argumentan
que esto tendría graves efectos en su
capacidad para producir rápidamente las
vacunas y acabaría con muchos empleos en
eeuu a washington también le preocupa
que al levantar las restricciones sobre
las patentes china termine con acceso a
tecnología bioquímica sensible el visto
bueno de eeuu es apenas un primer paso y
faltan varias rondas de diálogo el
consenso en la organización mundial del
comercio para que se suspendan las
protecciones de las patentes
[Música]
la unión europea asegura que está
dispuesta a hablar con eeuu sobre
suspender las patentes de las vacunas
aún así desde bruselas insisten en que
es un proceso extremadamente complejo
cada vacuna contiene aproximadamente 300
ingredientes que no siempre son fáciles
de conseguir ni de producir por ello
desde la unión europea insisten en que
ahora debe centrarse la solución en
exportar las vacunas y también en
aumentar la producción especialmente
países como eeuu o reino unido que se
han asegurado sobre todo en dosis para
su propia población pero se ha negado a
exportar vacunas la unión europea hasta
ahora en las últimas semanas ha sacado
pecho sobre la exportación de vacunas al
mismo tiempo que ha seguido vacunando a
su población y que es el primer donante
de kóvacs la iniciativa de la onu para
donar vacunas a los países menos
desarrollados los líderes europeos una
reunión la semana pasada aseguraron en
que la estrategia de exportar vacunas es
la correcta
[Música]
el presidente manuel macro me pidió este
fin de semana eeuu que levante las
prohibiciones para la exportación de
vacunas contra el coi 19 y sus
componentes según el el gigante
estadounidense ha exportado apenas un 5%
de las vacunas que ha producido en su
territorio y lo ha hecho países vecinos
como méxico y canadá el reino unido no
exportado ninguna vacuna sin embargo
dijo macro en la unión europea ha
llevado fuera de su territorio sobre
todo a países pobres la mitad de los 400
millones de dosis que ha producido y eso
explica en parte el retraso en la
inoculación de la población del viejo
continente de esta manera el presidente
francés sale al paso de las críticas que
recibió la semana pasada cuando se dijo
favorable al levantamiento de los
derechos de propiedad intelectual de las
vacunas contra kobe 19 siguiendo la
línea de joe biden en eeuu recordemos
que en el seno de la organización
mundial de comercio
sudáfrica india y brasil- vienen
presionando desde el año pasado para que
se levanten los derechos de propiedad
intelectual de las vacunas y puedan
producir sus propias dosis sin embargo
hasta ahora macrón seguía la línea
europea de qué sirve compartir la receta
si los países pobres no tienen ni la
capacidad industrial o tecnológica para
producir sus propias vacunas
[Música]